but this is quite common
no you didn't take me yeah
you was a bit violent when you took me
down there
i could resist you here you've given
them all this information he's confused
he's going will you just let me talk
about it
so since he never ever let us talk
we just tried
but things have changed
he stayed down there he's
that's good yeah that's good that's fun
come on that's it go on i need a bit
more punishment
okay
so eventually get in there and you're
getting so you're i can see you're all
going you're certainly well that's one
crank when it comes it should be
it should be like a
a gathering in
he doesn't know it's there until it's
there
and the whole thing the pin
becomes
the end of the movement
you okay so the only thing you're
looking for is not to go
that
right and you've all been there you all
know that one because you're perfecting
that one beautifully if you could just
perfect this
it's gathering in right
you won't get to here because this is
like six stan and upwards
stance
but what you want to try and minimize is
how much
you can make that movement
see there's too much
everything smiled kitten a smile smile
yeah i didn't say that
so that's that's the thing if you know
the techniques on you know you carried
it through all right you don't have to
keep adding
adding into it
so you're a long way off that try again
try not to give the
the kicker that last bit of
i've got it
because nobody likes that do they i
don't know anybody who likes the
sub and kick of a niccio
okay please again